c'est une histoire d'amour moi ce qui
m'a toujours intéressé propre temps pour
une gamine de 13 ans skins qui n'a
toujours si mes patients dans la vie ce
qui m'a intéressé un avis et c'est la
passion réciproque c'est l'amour
réciproque vraiment ça n'a aucun intérêt
et je vous assure
d'une manière générale si quelqu'un de
jeune quelques années j'ai pas qu'à 15
18 20 ans 25 ans tombe amoureux de
quelqu'un de plus âgé et bien si une
différence d indifférence
d'âge et bien la personne la plus jeune
doit faire au moins les trois quarts du
chemin bien sûr se passe rien
non puisqu'on peut dire aussi c'est dit
cela dit c'est quand même on a toujours
l'impression de devoir vabre continues
en non non mais dites moi a dit gabriel
non si vous voulez j'ai l'impression que
on peut le dire ça rapidement on est
après si on insiste trône un présentoir
je ne parle clairement ses aveux sujet
le principal et deuxièmement qui a
toujours une il faut toujours se
justifier
oui enfin on peut dire aussi à votre
décharge d'une façon y'a pas oui à damas
des chars vous n'êtes jamais je ne me
sens pas charger et je vais dire je n'ai
pas changé les gens vous le charge
est ce que les gens les imbéciles with
investi moi je préfère vous savez si la
fin il ya quand même une et moi moi je
préfère qu'on vous dit qu'à 14 15 ans au
xviie siècle les filles étaient mariés
voilà comme ça c'est plus c'est plus
simple non oui mais enfin écoutez j'ai
eu une fois une aventure avec une jeune
fille de 14 ans d'années ça ouais non
seulement c'est plusieurs années
ensemble c'était une très très grande
passion elle m'a inspiré un roman un
recueil de poèmes un thème de mon
journal elle le disait si tu as dit je
vais voir le président de la république
s'était mitterrand à l'époque et il m'a
dit je vais aller le voir je veux dire
qu'on s'aime et c'est donc voilà
[Musique]